before you were on saturday live and you
were kicking around and trying to get
your career going you were on uh in
living color with jim carrey
and jamie foxx and you're in that famous
sketch i thought it was one of his best
characters uh jim carrey was a um a
police officer who spits when he talks
and talks like this
and you're standing there and jim
carrey's like spitting all over you and
he's talking
but what an unbelievable thing to have
been a part of one of those early jim
carrey schedules
so talented yeah right i just got to
watch it behind the scenes and and
believe me howard when he comes to snl
what a force he just elevates everything
like it's like
oh he's like a powerhouse and just it's
crazy he'll just what about this what
about this ad stuff just open and
intelligent and i mean
he's incredible like when you get a a
guest host yeah like a jim carrey you
say in your book jim carrey alec baldwin
jennifer aniston queen of paltrow
gwyneth paltrow those people come to
play and they'll do they play like
gwyneth and jen could be cast members
they're just fun elegant yeah jen
anderson especially has fun and they
look gorgeous i mean and no ego about
the image in other words they'll make
fun of themselves oh yeah they make fun
of themselves
yeah i remember you did the uh sketch of
whitney houston you described in your
book how you uh you you you befriended
her and got her to be in the sketch with
mary katherine gallagher yeah and uh
that's that's great that you did that
and uh whitney was so nice they were
like she's not gonna be in this sketch
she's not gonna do it and i was like
she'll do it let me go talk to her and i
cause sometimes i would see where they
would approach the musical guest and
they would have too many lines or it's
too confusing and i thought they don't
want to have all this pressure
memorizing these lines right so i just
told whitney look i'm going to play the
catholic school girl you're going to be
like a snotty girl and it's all you have
to do is just do whatever you want you
just have to kind of
be you know snotty push in front of me
out sing me and so you can say whatever
you want she was like perfect i'll do it
i'll do it so that's how i got her to do
it and that's what i meant i was like
don't even don't even look at these
papers you know just have fun and so she
didn't then the night that it was the
sketch was on she was not there yet and
i was like oh no so they had on augusta
or dress in the catholic school office
so she was ready to go on stage it was
like
honestly like five seconds like they're
counting down she's about to go on and
then they're like whitney's here
whitney's here they usher on and she was
fantastic oh thank god she showed up she
showed up and she was it was rosie
o'donnell and whitney rosie was great in
it
because she was good with josie was
really good in that sketch yes she was
so good and whitney was so nice after
she loved being in that and she was like
girl you're crazy